i don't know how you passed the time
during lockdown but my family watched a
lot of sports and because leagues were
so determined to play through the
pandemic sports essentially became a
giant science experiment
or as my wall street journal colleague
andrew beaton wrote this was a year in
which professional athletes were the
world's biggest tallest strongest
fastest lab rats we learned a lot from
them and now with football season
beginning just as the delta variant is
causing coronavirus cases to surge
across the country we're likely to learn
even more about the virus as teams hit
the field and fans pack into stadiums i
definitely say the risk is up for
everybody
but it's just kind of our reality to
understand how athletes have been put in
the unique position of being able to
help us understand and cope with the
virus i called that wsj sports reporter
andrew he usually writes about athletes
and championships and multi-million
dollar contracts but for the past year
and a half it's been this split between
sports reporter and science reporter
because in order to cover sports smartly
and responsibly you had to cover the
science so what have we learned let's go
all the way back to the beginning of the
pandemic when pro basketball players
taught us that asymptomatic cases were
common and were fueling the spread of
covid19 breaking news here on cbs sports
hq and it is monster as this cbs sports
hq video shows days after nba player
rudy gobert touched microphones and
mocked the league safety protocols he
tested positive for kovan 19. tonight's
game
fans were sent home from games and pro
basketball went dark it's just
unbelievable just not something you ever
could have anticipated after gobert got
sick eight other teams were tested and
more than a dozen positive cases were
discovered he taught us that we should
take the virus seriously but we also
learned something else from that from
the fallout of his positive test right
yeah i think he obviously became the
face of it because of his role but one
of the interesting learnings that came
from these nba players was many of the
nba players who tested positive never
felt sick at all first of all how are
you feeling this morning
i'm fine it was a moment when many of us
learned the term asymptomatic
remember all of this happened at a time
when nba players had privileged access
to tests that the rest of us couldn't
seem to get soon after professional
sports leagues suspended their seasons
they began devising ways to play and
some leagues like the nba went as far as
to isolate teams on a campus better
known as the bubble basketball players
literally moved to disney world to
finish their season the bubble works
right the bubble totally worked and it
showed that
you know if you're going to take the
most extreme
measures and precautions possible you
could prevent this the bubble concept
might be impossible for other industries
to replicate since many of us living in
the real world can't afford to move away
from our families and work from disney
world but the more than 100 000 tests
that were conducted by the nba helped
inform all of us outside the bubble the
bubble data helped researchers figure
out among other things that if someone
recovered clinically from kovid 19 yet
continued to test positive they weren't
a risk to others 10 days in isolation
was enough to prevent transmission
then came football season and the nfl
quickly realized that the way many of us
were defining being in high risk contact
with an infected person was wrong how
the nfl didn't make players move to a
bubble but it administered nearly a
million tests on its 32 teams in 32
different communities over the course of
its season those 32 populations they had
data in so many different ways the
contact tracing the testing the genetic
sequencing
and so
where else in the world could you really
generate that type of information on
such a broad scale well that didn't
really exist back then a lot of people
thought that being in close contact with
an infected person meant being within
six feet of them for more than 15
minutes the nfl's data quickly showed
that that conventional wisdom was
inaccurate and that the virus was still
being transmitted beyond those
parameters the leak made changes to its
protocols and its findings were laid out
in a paper published by the cdc
and since the nfl was doing so much
testing it also set out to find a rapid
and accurate covet test we're talking
faster than that standard pcr test and
more accurate than the widely used rapid
antigen test and that was hugely
valuable for
a league where you know if you're going
inside the building you might be
spreading it to teammates inside the
locker room time is money in the nfl
time is definitely money in the nfl and
being able to have a test that was both
fast and accurate was kind of the dream
scenario together with two biotech
companies the nfl studied a rapid point
of care test that delivered on-the-spot
results in 30 minutes and they found
that the results matched the standard
pcr tests that the players were already
taking according to bioreference a
company that runs the test the nfl's
work is now helping inform the cruise
industry school districts sports and
entertainment venues and other employers
and finally there's heart research at
one point when there were major concerns
about how the virus impacted the heart
it was athletes from the wnba nhl mlb
and beyond that underwent rigorous and
expensive screening that helped us learn
more these are the types of things that
you can't necessarily execute if you're
an average person but they provided a
learning that would actually apply to an
average person all of that screening
contributed to a study that showed
encouraging results
luckily it found that long-term heart
complications in non-severe covet cases
are unlikely something all of us weekend
warriors and amateur athletes could take
comfort in
now with questions still swirling about
breakthrough infections and the
transmission of the delta variant we're
likely to learn even more from sports as
the pro football season kicks off the
nfl has all but mandated vaccines for
players and some venues are asking fans
to show proof of vaccination too
we're entering this new strange stage of
the pandemic where we know that the
delta variant is making things dangerous
we know vaccinations are making things
safer but at the same time people are
attempting to return to normal and for a
lot of people normal means football and
football crowds professional leagues
like the nfl are continuing to test
research and study the effects of covet
as for the rest of us we'll probably
still be spending a lot of time at home
but at least we'll have something fun to
watch on monday nights if you want to
learn more about how scientists are
turning to sports check out the link
below for more of andrew's work and if
you like this video be sure to subscribe
so you can join me as i report on more
news that's having an impact on our
lives
go broncos